[Music]
now i think we're down to
uh three cities left to announce in the
stadium tour this is the last year for
it anybody who [ __ ] about anything in
this business should be slapped so i'm
trying not to complain at all
put a stadium together and here comes
the pandemic here comes the weather it's
all the things you never had to worry
about when you got to play indoor right
so uh that's that's the only reason it
just seems like for the banner crew
i'm just gonna say it's too much they're
not complaining whatsoever they work
hard they just for me watching them do
all this i would much rather have a roof
over my head and if you get to play for
say seventy thousand people here
the next time you play here if you're
gonna play for seventy thousand about
five nights indoor i'd be happy to do
that because it's better for the bandit
crew and it's better for those people
that come see you if there were going to
be another tour that you would that you
could go hey what would you want to do
i'd like to go to dive bars 75 of them
let's line them up let's let's go cause
those are those are the most fun you can
have that's
somewhat legal
[Music]